let's go next to our caller from the
3:09 area code caller from 3:09 what's
your name and of course where are you
calling from very important details hi
David this is Sam from Texas hey Sam
what's up yeah so I'm a Bernie supporter
who will be voting Biden in November
okay
I talked to a fellow progressive on
Facebook he was posting something
that'll never Biden stuff and thankfully
I'm a viewer of your show and a member
because I used some of the arguments
about how he brought up how Biden is
more helpful to the progressive movement
and he actually said he was warming up
to that idea but he brought up something
really interesting I think you could
have a good perspective on he said he
can't vote Biden because of his past
policies and how a lot of the previous
votes in the Senate sort of contradict
the current platform or it has appeal to
progressive values right and he said
that a lot of like his past policies I
got a strong so I guess it was like
people who want to convince that
providing people to vote provide and how
do it convince and like how do we help
them reconcile that listen it's a matter
of its this is simply a matter of D do
you want to win and do you want to
reduce harm by getting Trump out Trump
was pro-choice for 68 years of his life
he completely transparently said and it
was it was transparently dishonest when
he said as he was becoming a Republican
candidate oh I am pro-life now I'm
against abortion abortions terrible jail
the doctors jail the mothers right like
he said every crazy thing and the
evangelicals said we're gonna vote for
the guy because that's what he says his
policy is now and we at least somewhat
credibly believe that this is how he
will govern and he has Donald Trump
spoke to them you know the March for
life or whatever and and whatever the
case may be with Biden the policies are
more complex than simply are you for or
against abortion there is no question
that Joe Biden in the 80s and 90s was
running a more conservative platform as
Senator than he is espousing for 22
but this is just the this is how things
work people don't have you know there's
this idea that has become popularized
with Bernie Sanders that if you have the
same idea for 40 years the same position
for 40 years it's objectively better 40
years is a long time and things change
during those 40 years many of the people
who in the last five years have become
large advocates strong advocates of LGBT
rights 20 years ago we're probably
pretty homophobic by today's standards
and if that's going to be the standard
we'll just lose I mean it's like I would
say we're just gonna lose if that's the
case is Biden going to do everything he
claims he's going to do of course not
just like Bernie wouldn't be able to
just like Trump hasn't been able to but
that seems like a very poor reason that
Biden's policies have changed therefore
we want Trump to win it seems crazy to
me yeah I know I I 100% agree and I also
tried bringing up to him that I think
Biden will keep people around him
that'll kind of like I think the people
of Biden will keep around him are gonna
have I'll be pushing for those
progressive values and I also tried
explaining how you know aoc or someone
like that or progressive has a better
chance of meeting with Biden to discuss
policy than they do with meeting with
confidence know what I mean of course of
course in a Biden presidency the aoc
wing at least will get a voice and a
hearing they might be will ignored 98
percent of the time but with Trump in
the White House they don't even have
they don't even get a hearing they have
zero voice you're absolutely right Sam
and in fact you know Trump campaigns on
actively hating yellows values that's
right so I it's such a ridiculous
position in my opinion Sam you do it
you're not falling for it which i think
is good yeah absolutely
good all right Sam excellent to hear
from you very much appreciate the phone
call